ein helikopter jagd elefanten
es sind zu viele hier in st simbabwe sie
zerstören die vegetation die elefanten
müssen reduziert werden
ich bin seit vielen vielen jahren
überzeugter naturschutz und das was wir
hier in san geschaffen haben wird
finanziert zu einem erheblichen teil aus
dem einkommen der nachhaltigen jagt das
heißt trophäen jahr muss das sein
ginge es auch anders
wenn wir hier in unserem gebiet das
mittel der jagd einsetzen müssen um die
tiere zu retten dann haben wir versagt
doch der schutz der tiere vor will daran
ist teuer
wie lässt sich das finanzieren dort wo
tourismus nicht funktioniert kann die
trophäenjagd helfen tiere zu schützen
und wohin mit den gefräßigen giganten
eine spektakuläre rettungsaktion beginnt
die elefanten ziehen um
was muss passieren damit sie langfristig
sicher leben können
[Musik]
tango ist ein privates wildreservat in
simbabwe
es liegt im südosten des landes und
erstreckt sich über eine fläche von 600
quadratkilometern
eigentümer ist wilfried papst ein
deutscher kaufmann
er hat sich hier ein kleines paradies
geschaffen mitten im wilden afrika
[Musik]
habs leidenschaft für wildtiere begann
1965 auf einer fotosafari
[Musik]
ich bin fasziniert von elefanten wenn
man die betrachtet wenn man sieht wie
die familien miteinander funktionieren
wie die miteinander spielen das fast
etwas menschliches drin
wir haben waren gestern unterwegs und
haben uns die wilden unbeeindruckt wie
ein kindergarten zu hause oder ist das
irgendwie anders da ist eine nähe da ist
eine eine wertschätzung dass eine liebe
wenn man so will
zu diesen speziellen 1993 kaufte papst
st es liegt im silver valley conservancy
einem naturschutzgebiet größer als das
saarland
damals gab es hier nur bankrotte
rinderfarmen giraffen elefanten
nashörner und löwen gab es nicht
papst und seine nachbarn siedelten die
ersten knapp 600 elefanten und andere
arten neu an
der betrieb von django kostet papst nach
eigenen angaben im jahr rund eine
million euro
etwa 60 prozent davon werden durch die
so genannte nachhaltige nutzung
finanziert das heißt trophäenjagd
großwildjäger reisen an und schießen ein
tier um sich den kopf samt hörnern oder
stoßzähnen an die wand zu hängen papst
wurde wegen der trophäenjagd auf seinem
land bereits angefeindet aber zurecht
der mythos ist es die jagd bei uns die
ganze tierwelt zerstört gejagt
nimmt ganz wenige tiere raus wenn wir
zum beispiel 100 leoparden haben und wir
schießen davon im jahr vielleicht vier
wir haben mal war eine nachwuchs rate
die sich sicherlich irgendwo bei 10
bewegt dann ist das nach wie vor
nachhaltig da wird also keine keine
leoparden bevölkerung irgendwo
vernichtet während der dreharbeiten
findet eine leoparden und löwen jagd
stadt gefilmt werden darf sie nicht zu
groß ist die angst vor der wirkung der
bilder die jagd erfolgt bei papst nach
festen ethischen regeln
so ist es zum beispiel tabu ein tier am
wasserloch zu schießen
in der regel werden einzelne meist
ältere tiere geschossen die ihre gene
bereits weitergegeben haben
bei löwen kann es aber auch schon mal in
rudelführer treffen
die konsequenzen sind einkalkuliert sagt
papst bei einer löwenjagd haben wir das
problem dass wir teilweise auch wollen
dass der nachwachsende männliche löwe
die die nachkommen seines vorgängers
frist so simpel ist dass das wollen wir
bei uns weil wir ansonsten unsere unsere
überzahl an löwen nicht in den griff
kriegen
es wird aber in jedem falle bei jeder
jagd bei jedem was wir uns vorstellen
abschließen zu wollen immer auch die
folgeschäden werden dabei berücksichtigt
ganz entscheidend für die nachhaltige
jagd sind zuverlässige zahlen
nur wer weiß wie viele tiere da sind
kann entscheiden wie viele geschossen
werden dürfen ohne die population zu
gefährden
in lankow wird jedes jahr gezählt am
boden und aus der luft derzeit läuft
eine spezielle leoparden zählung dafür
hat ökologe alexander kuba knapp 140
köder aufgestellt sie sieht haben wir
hier am baum ein köder befestigt ein
baumstamm mit nach oben
das zwingt die raubkatze den stamm hoch
zu laufen
die kamera ist an der seite so dass von
jedem tier die rechte seite fotografiert
wird das fell hat ein einzigartiges
muster so können wir jedes individuum
identifizieren
der ökologe berät papst wenn es darum
geht von welcher art genug oder auch zu
viele tiere da sind das konzept einzelne
tiere schießen um die übrigen zu
schützen
die einnahmen aus der trophäenjagd
fließen in den betrieb von django sie
decken laut papst in etwa die gesamten
löhne und gehälter der mitarbeiter
die meisten von ihnen leben in den
dörfern rund um st und ernähren mit
ihrem einkommen ganze familie
naja die communitys sind zunächst einmal
damit eingebunden weil wir auch 135
menschen er bei uns angestellt haben die
dann wiederum mit einem faktor von zehn
insgesamt wohl um die 1300 menschen
ernähren
daraus ergibt sich dass wir gute
beziehungen zu der bevölkerung um uns
herum haben weil wir nicht nur gehälter
zahlen sondern auch fleisch zur
verfügung stellen
auch das fleisch der tiere die als
trophäen geschossen werden wird an die
mitarbeiter verteilt
etwa ein drittel der mitarbeiter sind
ranger papst beschäftigt allein 44 man
die die tiere vor wilderern schützen
hinzu kommt eine elitetruppe die von
papst unterstützt wird diese ranger
schützen nicht nur die tiere ins allgäu
sondern im gesamten sabelli
naturschutzgebiet sie sind auf bedrohte
arten wie nashörner spezialisiert preis
clemmons leitet das team
er und seine leute sind sozusagen die
bodyguards der nashörner jeden tag auf
unseren patrouillen spüren wir die
nashörner auf und prüfen ob alles ok ist
wir suchen nach menschlichen spuren wenn
wir welche finden dann verfolgen wir sie
und nehmen die wilderer fest ohne
schwere waffen geht es nicht hier
draußen herrscht krieg sagen manchmal
kann es zu einem schusswechsel kommen
eine regelrechte schlacht das hatten wir
schon es kann sehr heftig werden
auf uns wurde geschossen wir haben
bilder erschossen
wir haben viele verhaftet wir haben
menschen verletzt es ist ein
regelrechter krieg da draußen
clemmons und seine ranger riskieren
jeden tag ihr leben um die tiere vor
wilderern zu schützen die trophäenjäger
die herkommen um ein tier zu schießen
nur um sich den kopf an die wand zu
hängen verachtet er sie töten aus dem
falschen grund sagt clemens er lehnt die
trophäenjagd ab auch weil oft eben nicht
ethisch gejagt werde
sammelgebiete wurden in der
vergangenheit weitgehend zerstört
gebiete in anderen teilen des landes sie
wurden über jahre in gebieten wo nicht
ethisch gejagt wird halten sich die
jäger nicht an die quote sie schießen
mehr als sie dürfen und sie suchen sich
immer die größten trophäen raus das
resultat ist dass die wildtierbestände
nach unten gehen
und dennoch obwohl bryce clemmons die
trophäenjagd als solche ablehnt erkennt
er an dass die einnahmen daraus dem
schutz der tiere dienen können wenn
verantwortungsvoll und ethisch gejagt
wird so wie hier in st ist es ethisch es
ist einer der orte wo ich weiß dass es
richtig gemanagt wird
sie arbeiten mit anständigen
ökologischen methoden sie studieren die
populationen und machen es nachhaltig
sie schießen auch nicht immer nur die
großen trophäen all ihre methoden sind
ethisch in st und sie sind sehr auf
naturschutz bedacht
unter bedingungen wie in st unterstützt
sogar die tierschutzorganisation wwf die
trophäenjagd selbst dann wenn es um
bedrohte tierarten geht der manager für
die politik der organisation spricht aus
was viele tierschützer nicht hören
wollen
wir erkennen an dass die trophäenjagd
unter bestimmten limitierten bedingungen
teil des naturschutzes sein kann
ein element davon aber meistens ist sie
nicht nachhaltig es gibt viele probleme
die damit verbunden sind das heißt aber
nicht dass wir ganz und gar dagegen sind
wir erkennen an dass es orte gibt wo sie
sich als nützliches mittel des
naturschutzes erwiesen hat das ist aber
eher die ausnahme und nicht die regel
trophäen für den tierschutz
das fühlt sich für viele falsch an
aber was wäre die alternative hier in st
simbabwe steckt in einer schweren krise
derzeit gibt es meistens nicht einmal
strom kann foto tourismus da
funktionieren
leider ist es sehr schwer touristen her
zu bekommen mussten sie überleben wir
müssen uns überlegen wir fliegen ja die
hauptstadt harare von außen herein
dann braucht es eine autofahrt von
ungefähr sechs stunden um hier in den
tiefsten tiefen bush zu kommen gibt sich
die frage gibt es beziehen meistens
nicht gibt es bargeld man muss sie
unterwegs auch was kaufen können auch
das gibt es meistens nicht
und es ist schon sehr sehr schwer in
diese weit entfernte wildnis traumhaftes
afrika auch tatsächlich als tourist zu
gelangen
unter papst hat sich sang go von einer
heruntergewirtschafteten rinderfarm zu
einem waldlauf paradies entwickelt die
zahlen fast aller spiel ziehen steigen
vor allem die der elefanten
aus den ersten 600 sind mehr als 2000
geworden
das führt zu konflikten mit den nachbarn
in den dörfern rund um das st berlin
naturschutzgebiet leben tausende
menschen und es werden immer mehr
aaron mondo bewirtschaftet zwei hektar
land direkt neben sanofi lernte er nicht
lf vans kommt die elefanten kommen von
django sie kommen auf unsere felder und
fressen und zerstören die pflanzen
es ist jedes jahr dasselbe mit den löwen
ist es das gleiche sie kommen und töten
und so viel es gibt zwar ein zaun um das
bild reservat allerdings werden
regelmäßig teile davon geklappt so kommt
es immer wieder zu konflikten zwischen
mensch und tier mondo hat eine hütte auf
sein feld gebaut um die ernte zu
schützen
wir kommen abends hierher für die nacht
um die tiere zu verscheuchen um unser
getreide zu schützen
aber wir können nur wenig dagegen tun
wir benutzen taschenlampen und trommeln
wie rufen laut go go go aber sie gehen
nicht wirklich weg sie laufen in der
nähe herum und wenn sie richtig hungrig
sind dann kommen sie so oder so dann
laufen wir weg
doch die elefanten zerstören nicht nur
die felder der angrenzenden firma sie
zerstören auch ihren eigenen lebensraum
[Musik]
wie man sieht hat ein großer elefant 4
567 tonnen schwer
den baum hier umgekippt ja einfach
abgebrochen
das ist an sich nicht das große problem
weil er sich jetzt davon der von der
krone ernähren kann
und vor allen dingen auch kleine
antilopen laub fresser leben davon
das ist sehr vernünftig das problem ist
der baum ist damit gestorben wir haben
inzwischen ein drittel unseres waldes
für dieser art verloren und das zerstört
die nahrungskette nicht nur für die
elefanten sondern auch für die anderen
lau presse das ausmaß der schäden ist
immens die elefanten machen selbst vor
den riesigen affenbrotbaum nicht halt
allgemein gilt 0,4 elefanten pro
quadratkilometer als akzeptabel damit
sich die vegetation erholen kann
papst hat erheblich mehr elefanten er
muss sie reduzieren sonst zerstören sie
ihre eigene lebensgrundlage part bekommt
die genehmigung 100 elefanten zu keulen
ganze familien sollen abgeschlachtet
werden kann es eine rettung geben
im norden simbabwes liegt riefer
800 quadratkilometer land direkt am
sambesi fluss der nürnberger
geschäftsmann ralf kusterer hat es
gepachtet er ist tierschützer aus
leidenschaft ein teil der einnahmen
seiner it firma hemmersbach fließt in
den schutz von wildtieren
die entscheidung dafür fiel auf einer
fotosafari ich war nach vielen jahren
safari als normaler tourist in südafrika
saß abends beim ranger habe ihn gefragt
was ein großes problem ist und dann hat
er weinend mir erzählt mann wie ein baum
dass er freunde verloren hat dass die
elefanten und nashörner abgeschlachtet
werden wie die fliegen und dann war für
mich in dem moment klar ich kann da was
dagegen tun ich kann den tieren helfen
mit hemmersbach im rücken können wir da
einen unterschied machen kostbarer
gründe die renault force eine
paramilitärische schutztruppe für
wildtiere
sie ist in südafrika und simbabwe aktiv
als kostbarer erfährt dass 100 elefanten
getötet werden müssen hatte er eine
spektakuläre idee die elefanten sollen
umziehen
eine einzigartige rettungsaktion beginnt
sie läuft über mehrere wochen
früh morgens geht es los aus der luft
wird nach einer geeigneten herde gesucht
die elefanten werden in kleinen gruppen
transportiert immer eine ganze herde
gemeinsam damit keine traumatisierten
einzeltiere zurückbleiben
[Musik]
auch am boden laufen die vorbereitungen
josua mostert gehört zu dem team das
sich um die gesundheit der tiere kümmert
er präpariert die pfeile mit denen die
elefanten betäubt werden sollen
dabei ist vorsicht geboten das mittel
ist auch für menschen gefährlich ist
hoch giftig für menschen eigentlich für
alle privaten das was hier jetzt drin
ist könnte mehrere menschen töten
ich weiß nicht genau wie viele aber es
ist sehr stark
muster zieht mehr pfeile auf als er
theoretisch braucht falls mal ein schuss
daneben geht
außerdem füllt er die pfeile mit
unterschiedlichen mengen des
betäubungsmittels so dass für jedes tier
je nach größe die richtige dosis zur
verfügung steht
der umgang mit dem betäubungsmittel ist
so gefährlich dass mostert immer ein
gegenmittel dabei hat einmal hat es ihm
bereits das leben gerettet
ich wollte das betäubungsmittel aus
einem unbenutzten pfeil herausnehmen und
es in eine kleine flasche füllen
aus sicherheitsgründen und um es später
zu entsorgen
während ich das tat sprang die nadel
heraus und die lösung spritzte in mein
gesicht
ich habe meine hände das gesicht
gewaschen und meiner frau gesagt was
passiert ist sie ist tierärztin
dann habe ich weitergemacht aber etwa
eine minute später habe ich gefühlt dass
etwas nicht stimmt es hat nicht einmal
eine minute gedauert
plötzlich hatte ich probleme zu atmen
und ich habe nicht mehr richtig gesehen
in dem moment hatten wir das gegengift
und haben es in mein bein muskel
gespritzt
ich erinnere mich kaum daran aber meine
frau hat es glücklicherweise auch
geschafft mir das gegenmittel auch noch
intravenös zu spritzen
es hat länger als einen tag gedauert bis
ich mich wieder normal gefühlt habe
innerhalb des dort fliegen dann ist es
soweit der helikopter hält die herde in
schach die elefanten werden aus der luft
betäubt es ist ein gefährliches manöver
tierärzte und helfer am boden müssen
möglichst nahe bei den elefanten sein
wenn sie betäubt werden
dabei besteht die gefahr dass einzelne
tiere oder auch die ganze herde die
helfer angreifen
in dem moment wo die elefanten umfallen
zählt jede sekunde
wenn sie unglücklich stürzen und ein
rüssel blockiert wird können sie
ersticken
dieser elefant bekommt schwer luft sein
gewicht drückt auf die lunge
die helfer müssen was tun
[Musik]
dass er die elefanten nicht töten muss
bedeutet wilfried pabst viel das ist ein
emotioneller highpoint den kann ich gar
nicht beschreiben das geht mir ein
bisschen an die augen muss ich sagen
dass es hoch emotional diese tiere
umzusiedeln und zu sehen wie die am
anderen ende sich vermehren ein tierpark
wieder neu bevölkern der von von
wilderern entvölkert wurde ist der traum
aller naturschützer
[Musik]
doch zuerst müssen die schwergewichte
auf die transporter
gut an
es ist ein kritischer moment
jeder handgriff muss sitzen
die hitze belastet die elefanten
zusätzlich helfer kühlen sie mit wasser
die leitkuh der herde wird mit einem
sender ausgestattet so können die ranger
später die bewegungen der tiere
verfolgen
[Applaus]
die kleinen transporter bringen die
elefanten zu einem großen truck
dort wartet eine fest installierte box
sie steht direkt hinter dem trockenen
dem die tiere ihre reise antreten sollen
von dem transporter geht es erst mal in
die box
dort bekommen die elefanten ein
gegenmittel damit sie aufwachen
tierärztin jack la grange muss sich
beeilen wenn ein tier aufwacht während
sie in der box ist kann es gefährlich
werden
gerade bei kleinen elefanten ist schwer
einzuschätzen wie lange die betäubung
hält einer war sehr leicht er hätte eben
aufwachen können aber wir mussten ihm
doch etwas geben
noch etwas unsicher versuchen die grauen
giganten langsam auf die füße zu kommen
draußen wird der große treck auf den
zentimeter genau an die box man öffnet
wenn box und truck verbunden sind werden
die zwischen türen geöffnet
die elefanten können alleine in den
truck laufen
dieser transport besteht aus einer
gruppe von neun tieren
für sie beginnt eine reise in eine neue
heimat
[Musik]
einen tag später erreicht der truck sein
ziel mit vielen stunden verspätung
es gab technische probleme die
zugmaschine musste getauscht werden
nach 24 stunden im truck schnuppern die
elefanten einen ersten hauch von
freiheit ein bisschen stinkig sind sie
schon in dem provisorischen gehege
sollen sie erst mal zur ruhe kommen
unterdessen prüft beat clemmons das
signal des senders der leitkuh der
sender übermittelt die position des
tieres auf zwei verschiedenen wegen über
satellit und funk im moment bekommen wir
über den satelliten stündlich ein signal
so wissen wir genau wo sie ist
später kommt das signal nur noch alle
vier stunden so schon wir die batterie
wenn sie leer ist bekommen wir aber
immer noch ein funksignal clemmons ist
der chef der renault fonds hier in rief
er und seine ranger schützen die tiere
vor will daran wenn wir das tor jetzt
öffnen und zu sehen wie sie in die
freiheit laufen dann spüre ich meine
verantwortung es ist meine moralische
pflicht auf sie aufzupassen zu sehen wie
sie freigelassen werden macht mich
glücklich
dann kommt der große moment
die elefanten werden freigelassen
auf sie wartet ein neues leben in einer
neuen heimat
die herausforderung für die elefanten
sie müssen im neuen revier wasser finden
einen tag nach der freilassung machen
sich pi clemmons und ralph koster auf
die suche nach den elefanten
sie wollen wissen ob es ihnen gut geht
mit einer antenne fängt clemmons das
funksignal des senders auf und folgt ihm
die gruppe muss sich den elefanten leise
und gegen den wind nähern
damit die tiere sie nicht twittern keine
leichte aufgabe denn der wind dreht
zwischendurch und die elefanten bewegen
sich vier stunden sind sie in sengender
hitze unterwegs dann endlich sichten sie
die elefanten an einem wasserloch
es ist ein bewegender moment für
kostbarer die tiere dir vor dem tod
bewahrte in freiheit zu sehen
traumhafter dankbarkeit an und das ist
einfach dass die relevanz erhält hier in
riva gibt es viel platz für die grauen
giganten der tierbestand ist gering
jäger und wilderer haben ihn über
jahrzehnte minimiert in riva sieht man
was passiert wenn nicht nachhaltig
gejagt wird die kommerzielle jagd begann
hier in den 80er jahren sagt clemens es
startet riesch am effekt als es anfing
wurde ethisch gejagt die leute hielten
sich an regeln aber das änderte sich
sehr schnell
leider auf beiden seiten bei der
nationalparkbehörde und bei den jägern
nicht bei allen aber bei einzelnen
individuen jäger überredeten
behördenmitarbeiter dazu ihnen mehr
tiere zum abschuss zu verkaufen sie
haben viel mehr geschossen als die quote
erlaubte
die schädel getöteter elefanten erzählen
davon
es war ein lukratives geschäft
korrupte mitarbeiter der
nationalparkbehörde und unethische jäger
verdienten gut daran
während der tierbestand massiv
geplündert wurde
es kann jeder nach jäger nach jäger sie
alle bekamen ihre lizenzen
es ist eskaliert und wurde zu dem was
wir heute haben manche gegenden sind
vollständig leer geschossen als
kostbarer das gebiet pachtet will er die
jagd verbieten doch er stößt auf
widerstand bei der nationalparkbehörde
die verdient an jedem tier das sie zum
abschuss freigibt ganz legal die gelder
aus dem jagd lizenzen sind für die
behörde eine wichtige einnahmequelle
das heißt wenn rief war nicht gejagt
wird verliert die behörde geld der chef
der nationalparkbehörde hat mir ganz
klar gesagt dass wir im endeffekt alles
tun können solange er die gleichen
einnahmen hat ihr hätte wenn hier jemand
das gebiet bejagt die einzige
möglichkeit ist das zu kompensieren das
heißt wir bezahlen stand heute für tiere
die wir nicht jagen und damit haben wir
die nationalparkbehörde auf unserer
seite
seit januar 2018 gilt ein striktes
jagdverbot in rif
die renault force patroulliert das
gebiet aus der luft mit boten und am
boden
die ranger schützen nicht nur riefer
sondern auch das angrenzende gebiet eine
fläche von rund 10.000 quadratkilometern
kosten laut kostbarer mehr als eine
million euro im jahr als die renault
force 2018 die arbeit aufnahm stellte
sich heraus dass auch ranger der
nationalparkbehörde bildern sagt
kostbarer
hintergrund ist die dramatische
wirtschaftliche lage in simbabwe
die ranger hätten über monate kein
gehalt bekommen so kostbarer den chefs
haben dann gesagt geht raus ihr dürft
euch euren anteile holen jagd auf die
tiere die er braucht um ihre familien zu
ernähren was in ordnung ist in so einer
existenziellen situation
die nationalpark ranger haben natürlich
sich dann daran gewöhnt haben gemerkt
dass ich vielleicht auch mal was
verkaufen können und wie wir gekommen
sind war die nationalparkbehörde er
sozusagen der größten bilder wie groß
ist die gefahr dass einzelne ranger oder
der staat als solche den tierbestand
plündern
je schwieriger die wirtschaftliche lage
je ausgeprägter die korruption umso
größer ist das risiko vor allem deshalb
lehnt der wwf die trophäenjagd er
manche länder ist es sehr verlockend
ihre eigenen ressourcen zu plündern
vor allem dann wenn die
rechtsstaatlichkeit schwach ist oder
auch die führungen
das ist unserer erfahrung nach der
häufigste grund warum die trophäenjagd
scheitert und sich nicht mit unseren
kriterien vereinbaren lässt
die möglichkeiten des missbrauchs der
jahr gehören zu den gründen warum
kostbarer sie in rif war ganz
abgeschafft hat doch er geht noch einen
schritt weiter
er versucht auch seine nachbarn davon zu
überzeugen sowie carl van der riet 30
jahre lang betrieb er eine jagd lodge er
arbeitete als jagdleiter das heißt er
betreute großwildjäger von der reid
sorgte für ihre sicherheit führte sie
zum abschuss
er kennt die dunklen seiten des
geschäfts weiß wie viel druck sowohl die
besitzer eines wild gebietes als auch
die nationalparkbehörde ausüben können
denn beide seiten verdienen an jeder
trophäe
manchmal wird eine ja konzession nicht
korrekt genutzt wenn man einen besitzer
hat er versucht so viel geld wie möglich
durch die jagd zu verdienen
der übt dann druck aus so wie es
manchmal auch die nationalparkbehörde
tut sie üben druck auf dem jagdleiter
damit er liefert in so einer situation
kommt es häufig zu unethischem handeln
dann schießen sie auch die großen
raubkatzen im löwen rudel
auch trophäenjäger üben druck auf der
zehntausende euro zahlt fährt nicht ohne
trophäe nach hause
ob in solch einer situation ethisch und
nachhaltig gejagt wird hängt dann an der
standhaftigkeit des jagdleiter tarif hat
die waffe abgelegt er hat seine jagd auf
foto tourismus umgestellt leicht ist es
nicht denn jäger zahl erheblich mehr als
foto touristen in einem kleinen gebiet
wie unserem brauchen wir anstelle von
fünf bis zehn jagd gruppen im jahr fünf
bis zehn touristen am tag um dasselbe
einkommen zu haben wir müssen viel mehr
anbieten der finanzielle druck ist groß
wenn man umstellt von jagenden auf nicht
jagende kunden
foto stadt trophäen schießen kann das
modell hier im krisengeschüttelten
simbabwe funktionieren kosmalla ist
davon überzeugt dass es langfristig der
richtige weg ist
foto tourismus beschäftigt mehr menschen
lokal als aktivismus tut und es ist
sicherlich nachhaltige ich sage nicht
das ist nicht jagd konzepte gibt die
nachhaltig betrieben werden es ist aber
immer die schwierigkeit erst zu
überwachen insbesondere in afrika und
ich glaube daran dass foto tourismus der
bessere weg in die zukunft ist für alle
beteiligten
seit koslarer die jagd in riva gestoppt
hat und seine ranger die tiere vor
wilderern schützen erholen sich die
bestände die elefanten die aussage kam
mischen sich inzwischen mit den lokalen
elefanten hier in riva dass sie sich so
stark vermehren dass sie ihren eigenen
lebensraum zerstören muss kostbarer
nicht so bald befürchten denn im
gegensatz zu sagen go hat rief einen
klaren vorteil
wir haben riesenglück dass es hier
keinerlei vorne gibt die tiere können
über hunderte kilometer frei laufen bis
nach mosambik deswegen wenn es zu eng
wird dann werden die tiere weiter gehen
und damit werden wir nicht in die
situation kommen dass wir den
tierbestand in irgendeiner form managen
müssen haben weil es sich selbst
regulieren wird rief er hat noch einen
vorteil in dem 800 quadratkilometer
großen gebiet gibt es nur wenige
menschen und doch zeichnen sich die
ersten konflikte ab außerhalb von riva
an der grenze zu sambia liegt der runde
hier leben auf serbischer seite etwa
4000 menschen neben und mit den
wildtieren angezogen durch essensreste
und wasserquellen kommen nicht nur affen
sondern auch die grauen giganten
immer wieder kommt es zu zusammenstößen
zwischen mensch und tier die im
einzelfall auch tödlich enden
hinzu kommt ein weiteres problem die
elefanten fressen plastikmüll einzelne
tiere sind bereits verendet der magen
voller plastik
kostbarer hat deshalb ein projekt ins
leben gerufen die sogenannten maria
ladies zwölf frauen die in rundu den
müll von den straßen sammeln
jeder sagt den sie mit müffeln hat einen
gegenwert von 25 cent
dafür erhalten sie dann über die renault
force lebensmittel und hygieneprodukte
auf dem man am ende des monats zählen
wir die säcke und kaufen ihn dafür
lebensmittel und so etwas selbst indem
sie zb maisbrei erdnussbutter
waschmittel speiseöl zucker nudeln salz
wohnen oder auch logen es gibt vieles
bevor das projekt begann waren die
frauen arbeitslos viele von ihnen sind
alleinerziehend jetzt können sie nicht
nur sich selbst und ihre kinder ernähren
sondern auch noch hilfsbedürftigen
verwandten helfen sagen sie jede von uns
zwölf hat jetzt genug zu essen
vorher ging es uns nicht gut ich denke
dieses projekt ist sehr gut für uns für
uns alle für unsere gesellschaft für
unsere familien schon beim sammeln
trennen die frauen den müll
der einfache hausmüll wird später zu
einer müllhalde gefahren
alles was recycelt werden kann kommt zu
einer sammelstelle
es sind vor allem plastik und
glasflaschen
[Applaus]
die berge geben eine idee davon was die
frauen leisten und wie der ort ohne
ihren einsatz aussehe
[Musik]
von dem müll projekt profitieren
menschen und elefanten
doch langfristig wird sich der konflikt
zwischen mensch und tier hier
verschärfen denn die zahl der elefanten
wird steigen genau wie die der menschen
der lebensraum wird für beide enger
nicht nur in singapur
weil die bevölkerungszahlen in afrika
explodieren wächst der druck auf die
wild gebiete der kampf um die ressourcen
hat längst begonnen
wie können menschen und wildtieren
nebeneinander existieren wenn der raum
immer enger wird
wilfried pabst und ralf kusterer stecken
jedes jahr hohe summen in den schutz und
betrieb ihrer wild gebiete ob mit oder
ohne trophäenjagd unterm strich
schreiben beide rote zahlen
sie tun es weil ihnen das bilder afrika
am herzen liegt wer aber schützt die
tiere dort wo es keinen reichen spender
gibt kostbarer und papst sind überzeugt
es gibt nur einen weg
langfristig ist der einzige weg durch
die menschen die hier leben durch die
communitys die brauchen an den nutzen
von den tieren warum soll ich etwas
schützen wo ich keinen bezug dazu hat
und wo ich auch keinen nutzen davon
haben nutzen kann bedeuten arbeitsplatz
nahrung zukunftsperspektive aber das
muss geschaffen werden sonst ist es
unmöglich dieses thema zu lösen wenn
unsere wilden tiere keinen wert für die
lokale bevölkerung haben werden sie die
auch nicht schützen
stell dir vor die wilderer kommen
natürlich durch die dörfer wenn der wert
dieser tiere aber in den dörfern schon
manifestiert ist und denen das klar ist
werden die wilderer dort kein zuhause
finden das heißt der wert der tiere ist
elementar im überleben des naturschutzes
die einnahmen aus dem foto tourismus
schaffen solche werte
doch nicht jedes gebiet eignet sich
dafür auch wenn bilder wie diese
regelmäßig für empörung und hass
kommentare sorgen die trophäenjagd kann
ein effektives mittel für den tierschutz
seien
doch die risiken des missbrauchs sind
groß
am ende bleibt die frage welchen wert
haben elefanten nashörner löwen für die
menschen nicht nur ideell
eines scheint sicher nur wenn sich die
tiere für den menschen rentieren haben
sie langfristig eine chance zu überleben
[Musik]